eazy-e was my favorite rapper I used to
wear like a eazy-e shirt all the time
NWA dr. Dre all that type of stuff so I
used to write raps like that was the
music I liked a lot was raps I remember
but the first rapper ever wrote was
about sonic the sonic restaurant right
and I remember I went and read it to my
dad [ __ ] fat [ __ ] about Sonic the
burger joint you remember how it goes I
don't remember that one
no you need to recite the lyrics right
now you gotta find the arena now they
need you to fire original beat and
lyrics wrote to one okay dump poor man
live don't tell me this was a lot when I
was like in third grade four and then so
like I did like music and then when I
got into sixth grade is when like I
really started writing more rap music
and we performed at a talent show for
like our pod and we won right I wrote a
song called black shoes and we performed
it in front of everybody and it was cool
what was black she was about black she
put my black shoes on with the no white
shirt oh look at me like I look like
dirt forget them fools I ain't no fool I
ride on 20 photos on my way to school no
I ain't black but I ain't white ass know
I get a lot of stuff like I lost the toe
I got a lot of friends and a lot of
money
I don't like sugar but I like honey
honey I'm my favorite kind of food is a
cherry pop-tart foot eight I'm not that
tall so in the bathroom I pee in the
stock I know how to sing the ABCs black
just and Teller so I don't eat cheese
I'm about to go right about now Pat I
don't want to answer and a wit about boy
she's great no wonder you want to do how
the [ __ ] that was actually pretty tough
is it six this [ __ ] said he
popped our cherry cherry pop-tart and
explain to me what the missing told hey
so I wrote the lyrics right and my sixth
grade teacher shot on Miss : she was the
[ __ ] dopest I wrote him and she read
it and she's like no you got to change
these because they have to be school
appropriate so I forgot what I think I
was oh I think I put ho
somethin like that she gotta change it
so like the only thing is she was like
Alex you're very talented but oh no I
think it was I was like I got a lot of
uh get a get a lot of money like I lost
the toe or so like I lost the big toe or
some [ __ ] I think it was like I get a
lot of money and I get a lot of hoes I
think that's what I originally put and
she was a [ __ ] 12 year old I look at
my teacher ad like it well you know this
part where you say you're slicing a lot
of throats because you are the goat this
one here I'm snorting a lot of coke and
I just stole your boat [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's do this and here it says you stole
my purse and use my money is that true
the personal thing and you just broke
our trust yeah so like it letting you
know I was right expects I know and then
I think it was probably around like
freshman years where we started getting
into more meta music like hardcore and
my brother got a guitar for Christmas
and was playing and our friend Tony was
playing and then they were like oh we
want to start a band be our vocalist I
was just like all right so like almost
like a lot of my songs were rap songs so
a lot of like the band songs the moment
we got pretty good before we like
officially stopped doing it a lot of
them were rap songs and I would just
scream them so like I want you to do
that rap one more time yeah all right
there we go
hey bust a beat for me real quick boom
chick god hey
my black shoes on with a no white shirt
yeah people look at me like I look like
dirt forget them hos ain't no fool I
ride on 20 photos on my way to school
but no I ain't black but I ain't white
ass no [ __ ] I got a lot of stuff like I
lost the toe I got a lot of friends I
got a lot of money fan I don't like
sugar about our light honey honey hey
I'm in sixth grade I'm not that smart my
favorite gun is flowing with is the
cherry pop sorry no for foot a so I
ain't that saw so in that bathroom I pee
you in the star no I know how to do the
ABCs y'all not just one tell her so I
don't eat cheese not to go right about
now I don't want to answer my angel with
a bow
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fired oh yes I
somewhat someone that's watching this
needs to cut that up and put a beat to
it has to do that I have never been so
motivated in my life to eat pop-tarts
cut off my toe black shoes and look like
dirt hey you know what this is this just
follow your dreams kids I was watching
that that was cool about that right it
was cuz it was me and my friend at the
time ray he had a song called white
shoes I don't know the lyrics and you
said [ __ ] you naqshi but yeah we did
black shoes and white shoes and I
remember I wrote the song because my
picture ray upset at us [ __ ] he's like I
wrote it too cos my my auntie got me
some like Reebok with like the straps
over and sure they were all black cause
like Yogi's are fresh on my wearing my
dress today
leigh-anne kind of led into that and I
was doing rap music and [ __ ] like that
but rap was something that I could never
do I remember I wanted to do rap so bad
back in the day as a bunch of Asian
geeks and nerds do but you're too scared
to battle rap and this is like when MC
Jin came on shout out the Jew remember
106 & Park yeah man check it [ __ ]
something they probably made in China I
forgot that I'm sorry it's vegan name is
sterling because all you rock is silver
Oh
the first battle rap that he did
shout-out to MC gene he was battling
this dude Hassan and I remember a Fatman
Scoop was like worried about Hassan and
he goes no Hassan get focused and I
think when he said that it kind of
ruined his confidence a little bit
he just [ __ ] rocked him and it was
funny because back in the day when they
were doing battle reps and still to this
day like you know the only thing you
really got against an Asian guy is
racist Asian jokes yeah so I remember
his first thing is that you don't want
to mess with this cat Hassan I'll get
you back in the cut you cooked cooking
fried wontons
yo and I was like oh and that's a
tundish it was a hot [ __ ] line but
then Jenna was so [ __ ] good at that
106 and park battle he was just
murdering I feel like I never lost I
remember he like he would he would
always win no he won every single round
that's how he that's how he got that
[ __ ] lame
deal with Rough Riders mm-hmm Yeah right
dude
and then he no yeah then he dropped that
[ __ ] song y'all gonna learn Chinese
which was a trash song it was sad
because like he wanted to rock with
Rough Riders because I was like his [ __ ]
and they didn't market him correctly he
had him do a song called y'all gonna
learn Chinese it's like mom Ruff Ryders
was like DMX and [ __ ] right okay that's
why I told y'all suboxone no hey no no I
loved yo shout-out to DMX as well you
[ __ ] insane I wish like so I like I
like I wish I could sing so it's funny
like you wait you never got into rap
right did you want to get into rap you
said you go i would i would write [ __ ]
and it just sucked yeah I've always
wanted to be able to sing but like I
can't really sing so because I used to
when I used to try to rap like I I think
I have a very good general knowledge of
music I know when [ __ ] sucks and I'm
like this is gonna be far right you know
hit that B I start rapping I'm hahaha
couple disappear and I thought I was
getting high school as well it's it's
hard like yeah I was doing it I was
writing raps from when I was like in
third grade when I wrote about Sonic so
I would just write a bunch of [ __ ]
how'd you wrote now how can you remember
the [ __ ] sixth grade one dog that's
like four years
don't you remember that TV recall